[Music]
to be able to be doing science while
you're out there on the surfboard
surfing down the face of the wave it's
just such a fleeting moment it's
incredible to actually be able to do it
smartphone is a surfboard fit you clip
it on the bottom of your board and you
go out for your surf sessions it has
technology that measures ocean pH
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they are shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we have detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they are just not
deployed at the coast bingo
smart fin can fill that gap collecting
oceanic data is a very time-consuming
expensive process this is like you just
need to know how to surf the data moves
from your fin to your phone via
bluetooth and then from your phone it
goes up to our servers where
everything's processed
I had to develop sensors that don't
affect the surfboard
nobody's gonna surf a fin that is not a
standard foil aside from that LED right
there is blinking that tells you that
there's like some sort of technology now
you wouldn't know the difference so
we've got a test tank set up now and
we're just trying to look at the
precision and accuracy of the instrument
itself things are looking pretty
promising
as a scientist it's pretty exciting to
be able to get data over these different
time and space scales I mean the fact
that you can go out and surf and
contribute to understanding what's
actually happening out there is
incredible I'm not a surfer I know
nothing about surfing I know I looked
like a surfer but um I'm not surfers are
very influential and care deeply about
the environment and want to be talking
about it
so smartphone is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way
[Music]